it had happened again some absolute
schmuck of a junior researcher had left
a certain door ajar the door that kept
scp-049 the plague doctor locked in his
containment chamber as a result the good
doctor had wandered out and given the
junior researcher a hug of appreciation
for freeing him leaving his dead body
sprawled out across the ground typical a
problem solving itself but this time the
problem had been a little more severe
than just the one responsible facing
immediate consequences of their actions
the black doctor had grabbed the junior
researchers corpse and dragged him back
into his cell leaving the door once
again slightly ajar with a variety of
equipment from his magical medical bag
the doctor had transformed the junior
researchers quarks into a disfigured
zombie in hopes of curing him of the
pestilence and released him into the
facility 049 had followed him out to
observe his behavior and in the process
he'd given several guards and members of
janitorial staff a congratulate Tory
hand touch sending them to early Graves
by the time people realize what was
going on six people were dead several
zombies were wandering around the
building and 049 was spotted in a lab
stealing medical equipment Dr clef who
was on duty at the time was getting sick
of this nonsense this was actually the
third breach that the plague doctor had
been involved in this month and it was
only the 14th he was frankly ready to
wash his hands of this particular
anomaly because it wasn't just the fact
that the plague doctor killed people
that bothered Dr claff after all Dr clef
himself had killed a considerable number
of people it was the fact that the
plague doctor was also so damn
sanctimonious about it cleft breathed a
sigh and rubbed his temples to subdue
the incoming headache it was time to
have a little tribunal and decide what
disciplinary action he would take
against this freaky physician the plague
doctor was on his knees locked into
place by heavy chains and restraints
around his neck arms legs these weren't
even official Foundation property Dr
Cliff had brought them in from his
private Leisure room back at his house
as usual the doctor was preaching the
immense value of his work the pestilence
runs Rife Dr clef surely you must see
that the doctor cried you're a man of
science yourself allegedly surely you
can empathize with my mission I just
want to help people can't you see I'm
just like you blah blah blah oh is this
goddamn pestilence do you ever turn off
cliff said waving away the doctor's
words I don't know about your pestilence
but I'm definitely looking at a pest
right now what the hell am I supposed to
do with you no matter what allowances we
give you you just keep escaping the
doctor hung his head he hated when
people treated him like this like some
wild animal of course occasionally
people died but it was only in the
pursuit of saving so many more lives he
tried to convince Dr clef that the costs
would pale in the face of the rewards
but the gung-ho Foundation researcher
simply wasn't interested
instead he was brewing up a new idea one
that might rid him of the plague doctor
forever even without breaking the
foundation's goofy rule against killing
anomalies you know what Dr clef said
affecting a voice of mock kindness you
finally got your words through my thick
head I get it now I get how important
your research is all this time we've
been stepping in the way of Nobel
prize-winning work I don't know how I'll
ever live with myself for this I just
want to say personally on behalf of the
SCP Foundation we are truly sorry
suddenly the plague doctor perked up my
goodness he thought I finally gotten
through he was practically vibrating
with Glee your apology is accepted good
sir the plague doctor proclaimed let us
not to obsess over the past we will look
towards the future exactly Dr clef cut
in that's why by wave and apology I plan
to reassign you to a special research
facility where you get to run the show
you'll have live test subjects of Plenty
and no accountability to the foundation
whatsoever how does that sound to you
back the blood doctor somehow Rose to
his feet despite the chains perhaps
propelled by the sheer force of his love
for science I suggest we leave at once
he said thank you Dr clef you kind kind
man I always knew that you are the
reason for one even Dr clef had to
resist the urge to laugh about that one
smash cut to the next day when Dr Clough
the plague doctor and a group of mobile
Task Force officers were crowded into a
helicopter heading towards
scp-3008 also known as the infinite Ikea
of course the plague doctor didn't know
that he thought he was heading towards
the state-of-the-art research facility
that Dr clef promised him clef on the
inside reason that what this bird brain
[ __ ] didn't know wouldn't hurt him the
helicopter landed within the perimeter
established around the abandoned Ikea
and the plague doctor was herded off the
vehicle he bought cleft's lie Hook Line
and Sinker and as such was unusually
Cooperative with the guards Dr clef
pointed to the building and instructed
the plague doctor to head inside and
just keep walking he'd find the test
subjects and the facility soon enough
and why would the foundation be lying to
him they'd even let him take his medical
bag in there when you get in there ask
for cue he'll be your lead assistant Dr
clef told him leave the system you mean
to tell me I will have multiple research
assistants the plague doctor said oh
Splendid I cannot wait to meet this Hugh
oh yeah Dr clef said biting his bottom
lift to stifle a laugh his name's Jazz
be sure to mention that it'll help speed
along the process the plague doctor
nodded his head and thanks much
appreciated Dr clef rest assured I will
not forget this kindness as the plague
doctor wandered into the abandoned store
his heart swelling with pride Dr clef
began to quietly laugh behind his back
like the big old jerk face he was when
he could no longer see the plague doctor
cleft turned to one of his colleagues
and jokingly asked does that mean we'll
need to reclassify 3008 as tomuel now
not looking forward to that paperwork on
the inside of the infinite Ikea the pike
doctor was chuckling to himself with
Glee after all these years of hard work
his Merit had been recognized and he'd
been given the respect he deserved from
his peers at the foundation he was so
wrapped up in his own sense of personal
Pride that he didn't even register it as
strange that he was surrounded by odd
sterile living rooms bedrooms bathrooms
and kitchens all in a seemingly random
configure duration with signs next to
them in a mix of The King's English and
what he believed to be some form of
Swedish that he didn't quite understand
still he didn't mind too much he just
assumed that these must be the
accommodations for himself his patience
his test subjects and his research
assistants had to think they'd built
this whole place just for him and his
research it lifted his soul to know that
the SCP Foundation had finally
recognized the pestilence for the danger
that it is from now on everything would
change he'd probably find the Cure in
the next few years then it suddenly
occurred to him he was a little lost the
layout of the research laboratory was
incredibly strange it seemed like an
utterly arbitrary configuration of
bizarre rooms separated by wide aisles
it didn't seems sanitary at all where
were the sealed Laboratories the gurneys
the patient beds the medical equipment
and on top of all that where was Hugh
some kind of shenanigans were foot that
much was clear now the plague doctor
after quickened his pace through the
halls of this strange building one way
or another he would get to the bottom of
this nothing would get in the way of the
important research he planned to conduct
here after what felt like hours of
aimless walking the plague doctor
encountered some other sentient beings a
group of three people wearing ragged
post-apocalyptic looking clothes all
carrying defensive kitchen knives and
hammers the doctor was overjoyed to see
these people he could actually converse
with the others upon seeing him were a
little taken aback had some renfare
cosplayer somehow accidentally wandered
into the building but on Earth was going
on here excuse me good Setters the
plague doctor called out I'm searching
for a huge ass that caused the group to
break into laughter immediately
lessening the tension the de facto
leader of the group Calvin replied
aren't we all zero four nine didn't get
it but these humans nonetheless like the
cut of this new guy's jab all three of
them had been in here for at least a
year each and had been a while since
they had a good laugh in this town
terrible Labyrinthian Place Calvin
stepped forward lowering his weapons now
that he could see that this weird
cosplayer guy didn't seem like a threat
he cleared his throat and asked mind if
I ask who you are fella the plague
doctor was taken aback by this question
did they not prepare you in advance for
my arrival the group shook their heads
how strange the plague doctor said well
I suppose some proper introductions are
in order then I am your new leader as
appointed by Dr clef of the SCP
Foundation I'm a reasonable man a man of
science and under my leadership we will
be a scientific Force the likes of which
the world has never seen together we
will cure the pestilence and save all of
mankind there was a long pause after
that none of the group of humans really
knew how to react to this Calvin thought
to himself great we got ourselves a
major space case let's get him back to
the camp before he gets himself killed
he forced a smile nodded pretending to
be impressed by the plague doctor's
bizarre ranting well then doctor he said
better get you back to our camp we're
not going to get anything done while
we're just standing around will we the
plague doctor couldn't agree more he
followed the group of his three new
research assistants further into this
incredibly strange scientific building
the black doctor indeed appreciated Dr
clef putting all this together for him
but he would privately indulge in the
thought that Dr clef seemingly could not
put together a laboratory to save his
life this place was a bizarre confusing
disaster but he would still make it work
one way or another however his musings
were interrupted When the Lights Went
Out the three people with him began
gasping in shock and horror Calvin was
repeating to himself no this is
impossible I timed it I swear I timed it
but the plane doctor found their
attitude to be utterly baffling these
were supposedly to be Intrepid man of
science and yet they were afraid of the
dark it seemed they really did need his
leadership to get anything done here
follow me gentlemen the plague doctor
said it's merely a failure of the lights
I'll get this rubbish sorted out he
began to walk forward as the three human
beings began to panic behind telling him
that if he keeps walking he'll die he
needs to come back they need to stick
together but he kept walking he didn't
get this far by being a coward after all
at least the others are following him
now wielding their Hammers and kitchen
knives he'd whip them into shape then
his attention was stolen by something
altogether stranger it was a creature
humanoid but not human standing about 10
feet away from him seemingly ignorant to
his presence the black doctor was
simultaneously fascinated and horrified
by what he saw before him it was in some
kind of yellow and blue uniform with a
hideous malformed faceless head and two
long Tangled arms that it dragged along
the floor behind it like an orangutan it
was a truly repulsive pitiful creature
one that made the plague doctor sad to
even look at it clearly this had to be
an advanced case of the pestilence while
the plague doctor was filled with
scientific curiosity his three human
traveling companions were filled with
Terror there were still so far away from
the camp and the staff had found them
already because there's never just one
they're like big deadly cockroaches if
you can see one more are on the way
their best bet is just staying
incredibly quiet and trying to sneak
past hello there you poor fellow the
plague doctor said stepping forwards and
waving it seems your entire need of some
medical assistance Calvin and his two
companions were mortified so this was
how they were going to die after making
the mistake of being kind to a clearly
deranged man dressed as a medieval
plague doctor what a way to go the
second it heard the plague doctor's
voice the member of staff was activated
as were several others in a 10 meter
radius they all suddenly stood upright
muscles taught with violence waiting to
happen they began chanting their dreaded
phrase the store is now closed please
exit the building while converging and
running towards the plague doctor like a
pack of hungry dogs it was a terrifying
sight to behold but not for the plague
doctor himself there were so many of
these poor infected people and clearly
the pestilence had not only warped their
bodies but broken their minds after all
this wasn't a store this was the new
Research Center specifically designed
for his research Dr clef would surely
never just lie about something like that
he was an honorable man then again maybe
that was exactly why cleff had sent him
here so many victims of advanced
pestilence would make perfect test
subjects a paradise of research the
plague doctor couldn't be happier as a
group of 10 staff members converged on
him Calvin and his men could barely look
the new guy may have been crazy but he
didn't deserve to go out like this
however the last thing they expected was
for the plague doctor to calmly raise
his hands allowing the members of staff
to run right into his deadly touch in
the following moments all 10 of them
were lying on the ground dead the three
men were utterly speechless what had
just happened had the man in the strange
costume snuck in a secret knife or a
sign gun had he gone into some hyper
Advanced instant kill Kung Fu move that
was simply too fast and subtle for them
to perceive or had he really just killed
10 members of Staff in mere seconds just
by touching them the play doctor turned
to them and said well then gentlemen let
us grab one each and we'll carry them to
the laboratory on the double soon after
the plague doctor and his three research
assistants arrived at the nearby
encampment several other members of
staff had attacked them on the way but a
single touch from the plague doctor had
killed each one the human's perspective
on this mysterious stranger had changed
entirely he'd gone from a goofy crank to
a Godlike Savior for as long as they'd
been in here they'd lived in Terror of
Staff but they were nothing to this man
with a single touch from him they were
gone forever as the doors of the camp
were closed behind him the people of the
camp began running towards them confused
and curious the plague doctor was
delighted to see that there were so many
other research assistants here to help
him on his divine
Dr claff that beautiful sweet man had
given him such a boon perhaps now the
pestilence May finally be cured one of
the camp leaders ran over Furious and
yelled what the hell are you doing you
know you can't just bring those bodies
in here it only attract more of them you
fool fool the plague doctor found this
rather rude but he'd Overlook it for the
sake of the greater good he'd spent his
whole life dealing with the aspirations
from lesser intellects who couldn't even
begin to understand his work the masses
rarely understand processes only results
and here he knew he would be able to
give them results
I am a medical man the plague doctor
said simply walking past the naysayer
and bidding his first three research
assistants to drag the bodies after him
I will bring this place up to code you
will see soon enough that my scientific
leadership is second to none now I will
retire to my office and begin dissecting
these samples before the camp leader
could say anything else the plague
doctor had retired into a staff room
which had been retrofitted as a kind of
headquarters for members of the camp
that's when Calvin approached the camp
leader and told him the astonishing news
look boss I know he looks like a
goofball in a Halloween costume he said
but this guy he's special he's something
else he can kill the staff the camp
leader scoffed so can we he said Calvin
shook his head no you don't get it boss
not like us this guy he can kill the
staff just by touching them and the camp
leader had no response to that in his
new study the play doctor was dissecting
one of the Dead staff members and was
astonished to see what was happening
within the creature had no organs it was
simply that strange slightly yellow
tissue all the way down he'd never seen
the pestilence have such a profound and
horrific effect on its victims it had
horribly altered them all the way to the
core was this what the great dying was
truly capable of in its later stages the
plague doctor shuddered both with horror
and scientific excitement he barely been
here a day and he'd made some of the
most incredible discoveries he took
fastidious notes on these new
Revelations feeling the picture coming
together in his mind his deep scientific
thoughts were interrupted by the door
opening and Calvin and the camp leader
stepped in the camp leader was different
than before he had none of the Bluster
and arrogance of his first words he
showed fealty like he was standing in
the presence of a Divine being I'd like
to formally welcome you to our camp
doctor the camp leader said we're
extremely fortunate to have you here
please if you need anything don't
hesitate to let us know we are truly At
Your Service the plank doctor was
delighted to hear this with a polite nod
he replied more tests subjects like
these would do just fine good sir I
believe I am very close to a
breakthrough here now go check out
scp-049 the plague doctor everything you
need to know and scp-049 what actually
is the pestilence the plague doctor
questions and theories for more on
everyone's favorite well-inten killer